the constraint on farms today in asia as
in america is largely because the
management is not appropriate
it just clearly says to you you've got
to focus on the agronomy
the next big jump is going to be
agronomy
how do you do agronomy
where do you where do you do agronomy
i've never known
in 50 years maybe
of a real impact coming from some sort
of agronomic research that was
experimented and
evaluated and
proven
out of an experiment station
i just don't believe it i think it's got
to be done on farms
under real conditions where the farmers
doing the planting incorporating
whatever suggestions the specialist is
telling them to do